today on the matt walsh show aoc posts
pictures of the crumbling shack where
her grandmother lives in puerto rico
she she blames trump for her
grandmother's living conditions but why
isn't she reaching into her own pocket
to help there's this is kind of
symptomatic of a larger problem in our
culture
which we'll talk about also five
headlines including the fouchy emails
revealing well basically what we already
knew i think which is that we've been
lied to repeatedly
in our daily cancellation a high school
valedictorian went off script during her
graduation speech
to slam the state of texas for
restricting abortion
there's actually quite a lot to be
learned from her remarks on the subject
though not the things she wants us to
learn
from them so we'll talk about that and
much more today on the matt wall show
it's truly been a banner week for
champagne
socialists we we start with this briefly
just because i think it's
funny a famous twitch streamer named
nicole sanchez and one of these days
i'll figure out
what a twitch streamer is she's well
known for her videos and posts
supporting
bernie sanders and she was fond has been
fond of wearing tax the rich
merchandise but she uploaded a video to
youtube this week
showing off her two million dollar
apartment two million dollars
if you're thinking there might be some
kind of contradiction here sanchez
explained in another recent video
that when she says tax the rich and
talks about all the evil rich people she
doesn't really mean all rich people
don't be silly i think she presents the
distinction pretty eloquently here
listen
all i'm doing is standing by the beliefs
that i started off with
and i'm here so um
whether i'm making this money or not i
just feel like
it's definitely not something to like i
guess like rude about because
there's nothing to be rude about i think
when people mean like taxi rich
i think at the end of the day they do
mean like billionaires and people that
have
insane unfathomable amounts of wealth
oh okay no i didn't mean i i meant
billionaires not
not millionaires you notice that bernie
sanders went through the same
evolution where he used to always be
railing about
the millionaires and billionaires and
then he became a millionaire
and and and he and he kind of shortened
it and now he was
worried only about billionaires so it's
funny how that works ironically though
in a certain way the fact that this
person
this nicole sanchez was able to become
rich in the first place is maybe the
best argument for socialism that i've
ever heard
still not very good one but it's the
best one in any case sanchez is but a
lowly foot soldier in the army of um
wealthy privileged socialist hypocrites
marching at the head of the battalion is
alexandria casey cortez
aoc last heard discussing her ptsd that
she suffered when some people trespassed
in a building close to the building
that she was in but not in the building
she was in tweeted this out on wednesday
afternoon she said
just over a week ago my abuela fell ill
i went to puerto rico to
see her my first time in a year uh
because of covid
this is her home hurricane maria relief
hasn't arrived
trump blocked relief money for puerto
rico
people are being forced to flee
ancestral homes and developers are
taking them
now you can see in the picture that her
abuela's
ceiling is falling apart there's water
damage
she appears to have almost no furniture
in the home except for one old chair
it's it's rather a sad site she has
buckets everywhere to collect
the leaking water truly squalid
conditions there's no question about
that
now aoc continued on in a lengthy thread
saying in part
we immediately got to work reaching out
to community advocates and leaders and
following the money
what's happening to puerto ricans is
systemic
much of it can be traced to legenda aka
the wall street connected fiscal
control board that the usa u.s gave
power to
over the island okay so her
grandmother's
ceiling is falling down and she's living
in a shack with one chair and buckets
all over the ground
and aoc saw this and immediately
got to work by reaching out to community
advocates
now i don't know about you but if i went
to a loved one's house
and i saw that pieces of their ceiling
were on the floor
alongside puddles of water i wouldn't
say
hang on let me get a community organizer
over here
now instead of reaching out to advocates
and activists why don't you reach out to
i don't know
home depot instead why don't you call a
repairman
why don't you give your grandmother some
of your own money to solve the problem
cortez makes at least 180 grand a year
and that's just her congressional salary
she has no children no dependents she's
a single woman with a six-figure salary
that's not counting whatever other
income streams she might have
she could sign a book deal tomorrow for
a million dollars if she wanted
she's one of the most famous figures in
america and fame can always be monetized
whenever she leaves congress if she ever
does
we can keep our fingers crossed she'll
be making six figures on a single paid
speech
the point is aoc is well off and and
and not just now she's set for life
so why isn't she forking over her own
money to help her own family
it's a fair question i think now under
normal conditions i would say that it's
it's none of our business how someone
spends their money and
whether they're giving their money to
their family members in need or not
none of our business but these are not
normal conditions because for one thing
aoc has
many ideas about how we should be
spending our money and is more than
happy to take our money and spend it how
she sees fit
also she's the one who brought her
grandmother into it she publicized her
grandmother's situation
in order to score political points she
used her poor abuela
as a cudgel against trump who isn't even
in office anymore
she introduced this personal situation
into the public conversation which means
we're all entitled to share our own
opinions about it
this of course is something people
always do now they in order to make a
political point or ideological point or
when an argument they
bring up some personal thing and then
that's supposed to to be an end to the
argument because then you're not allowed
to respond because if you do
they could always say well how dare you
this is none of your business if it's
not in my business why did you bring it
up
so i uh i responded to um to that tweet
and i and i said
uh tweeting back to aoc i said shameful
that you live in luxury while allowing
your own grandmother to suffer in these
squalid conditions
fair response i think and she responded
a short time later and her response i
thought was kind of revealing she said
quote
you don't even have a concept for the
role that first-generation first-born
daughters play in their families
my abuela is okay but instead of only
caring for mine and letting others
suffer i'm calling attention to the
systemic
injustices that you seem totally fine
with in having a u.s colony
now notice she didn't say that she was
going to help her grandmother
if she planned to help or had helped it
would have been a good time to
shut me up by saying hey i gave my
grandmother 50 grand to fix her roof and
buy some furniture
so butt out jerk she didn't say that
because it's clear that she is going to
wait for the government to fix a problem
that she could easily
and with little effort or sacrifice fix
herself
her concern she says is the systemic
issue
she's glossed over her own family member
suffering in order to focus on the
larger
broader systemic problem rather than
solve the one
issue she can personally and directly
and immediately solve
she'd rather talk about something bigger
and vaguer and which she cannot directly
do anything about
and this is exactly the problem not just
with alexandria cortez but with our
politics in general and our culture in
general
lots of people tend to stare helplessly
at broken things
that they could fix through their own
effort but instead they wait around
hoping the fix comes from above and by
above we mean
the government this is how people have
been conditioned
they've been conditioned to see their
struggles within a larger
and more ambiguous context
personal issues become systemic issues
what could be a personal fix now
requires a government policy
or program to address it you know in
catholic social teaching there's a
concept that's quite helpful
in illuminating whether you're a
catholic or not in fact there are many
such concepts in catholic social
teaching
this one is called subsidiarity and it's
a principle that says that
all issues should be handled at the
smallest and most localized level
possible
no problem should be addressed by a
large bureaucratic organization
which could be addressed by a smaller
and simpler and more directly connected
organization that isn't to say that
nothing should be done by large
organizations it just means that not
everything should be done
at that level in fact most things should
not be done at that level
the closest person to the problem should
fix it
if you ask me to pass you the salt i'm
not going to call someone in new mexico
to drive over here and
come into my house and pick up the salt
and give it to you i'm just going to
extend my own arm and hand you the salt
it's quicker easier simpler and a whole
lot less expensive that way
so aoc's grandmother this is just a good
example has a collapsing
sealant and water damage all over her
house
she can organize activists to call for
more funds to be sent from dc to the
puerto rican government
in hopes that it eventually finds its
way over to her abuela or or
or she could do it that way
a process that requires about 15
different steps and takes a long time or
she can reach into her own pocket pull
out her bank card
pay for the repairs herself by one
method
the problem maybe gets solved within a
year or two or three
or maybe not ever and the other method
the problem is solved immediately
and more cheaply and best of all she has
strengthened her bond with her
grandmother by performing this act
of love and service for her
it's much more humanizing one method
is direct relatively cheap
and also spiritually edifying the other
is indirect
expensive detached and cold the problem
you know is that in our country
we often choose the latter method
and that's exactly how we've gotten
where we are today
so help your grandmother aoc that's the
moral of the story
let's get now to our five headlines
you know one of the one of the the small
joys of
parenthood is uh just seeing the kinds
of
names and labels that your kids come up
with
for things um as they're sort of like
making sense of the world and that
that could always be a lot of fun and so
i i think it could be fun but it's also
a little terrifying at times so i had
this experience a couple days ago
um i was at home we were in the living
room at night and my
my four-year-old son who
he's always got a ton of energy he's
like a rabid raccoon running around the
house at all at all hours of the day
uh just full full of of energy but
this was it was getting late it was like
eight o'clock and he
he was had more energy than usual and i
was trying to figure out what was going
on with him
and then he said to me he said uh hey
daddy guess what and i said
what they said uh i
i found some i found some wild beans
i ate some wild beans and they've made
me strong and crazy
that's what he said and i thought for a
minute like
wild beans that you ate
that have made you crazy what the hell
did this kid find and eat and i'm
racking my brain now because i'm
thinking was he
did he finally did he eat like poison
berries from outside did he was he in
the medicine cabinet
this is a four-year-old he ate something
that he considers a wild bean
did he find like a crack rock and eat it
i don't think so i don't smoke a lot of
crack at the house so that he shouldn't
have been able to find that
um and then my but my wife quickly put
pieced it all together and realized that
he had somehow invaded
our uh our uh our pantry and we had a
whole bag
i guess of chocolate covered raisins and
he had ate the entire bag i don't know
how he got up there where he found them
i didn't even know he had them
he ate the whole bag and then he was on
a sugar high so that was the answer it
could be with it with a four year old
though
that could be anything wild beans that's
just a great
you know it's just a it's a great way of
looking at chocolate covered raisins i
suppose
all right let's go um
number one here from the daily wire it
says journalists obtained emails from
dr anthony fauci revealed that the
bureaucrat said in february 2020 that
surgical face masks
are not effective for healthy people
seeking to resist cova-19 infection
fauci has since repeatedly stated the
apparent importance of masks in relation
to the pandemic another email with the
subject line
my take on masks from fellow bureaucrat
andrea
lerner dated april 2021 has been nearly
completely redacted sparking some
speculation online
newsweek reported tuesday on fouchy's
email about surgical masks
ineffectiveness for the healthy dated
february 5th 2020.
um it says an email on february 5th 2020
he found she advised against wearing
masks
this is february 5th 2020 and said that
face mask bought in a store would not be
effective at protecting against the
virus
fauci wrote quote masks are really for
infected people to prevent them from
spreading infection to people who are
not infected
rather than protecting uninfected people
from acquiring infection
he said quote that continues the typical
mask you buy in the drugstore is not
really effective in keeping out virus
which is small enough to pass through
material
it might however provide some slight
benefit in keeping out gross droplets
if someone coughs or sneezes on you i do
not recommend that you wear a mask
particularly since you are going to a
very low risk
location in another there's another
email where he talks about
um where he admits that asymptomatic
spread
is very rare and these are all emails
again from over a year ago
and there are a ton of emails i mean i'm
sure you've heard about the foggy emails
by now
which are being released after freedom
of information act request i i have to
tell you that i don't quite
i'm not as into the fouchy email story
as others are which is why i haven't
talked about it much on this show and
the only reason
is that i'm not learning anything from
these emails that i didn't already know
if there's if there's one out there that
has some some real
breaking news i haven't seen it yet and
that's not to say that this isn't uh
infuriating
it's just that my contempt for fouchy
today remains what it's always been
because i always knew that he was
telling us one thing yet believing
another
i i knew that we were being lied to that
was clear from the beginning
now it and and most of this he actually
said publicly
so this the emails about masks that he
was sending in february
in march of 2020 advising people
personally oh you don't need to
worry about wearing a mask these emails
are getting a lot of attention at least
getting a lot of attention
in in conservative media we'll get to in
a second
how left wing media is interpreting
these emails
so we're getting a lot of attention but
the thing is fauci said
this publicly he's on the record
in public telling people that they don't
need to wear a mask
that's part of the story here it's been
part of the story
it's been a scandal from the beginning
that you had the so-called public health
experts
fauci the surgeon general also
infamously sent out a tweet early on
screaming at people in all caps don't
wear a mask
and that's what they said and then all
of a sudden
just like that it went from don't wear a
mask
you're an idiot if you wear a mask in
fact you're selfish if you're going out
and buying medical masks
you're hoarding them from people who
need them in in the healthcare industry
they went from that to you have to wear
a mask
all the time everywhere uh whether you
have symptoms or not whether you're sick
or not
and if you don't you're gonna kill your
grandmother and this transition happened
i mean literally overnight
and the explanation we've always been
given is that uh well the science
evolved
evolved but it did what's science
what what scientific breakthrough was
there between like
early february 2020 and april of 2020 in
in the span of a month or two what
information did we get
that told us that that rather than not
having to wear a mask hardly at all
everyone needs to wear masks everywhere
including outside including if they're
not sick what's science
what data what information where is this
evolution
can you show it to us
no they never can they never did
and that's because in my view the quote
evolution
um when it comes to masks was not really
it was not a scientific evolution it was
a political evolution
that's my view it's been my view all
along
and i think we knew all of this the
entire time
so there don't get me wrong there is a
scandal here
and fauci should be fired at a minimum
um but i i i knew that i didn't need the
emails to tell me that
now but the emails no matter how you
slice it
aren't flattering at the very least um
unless you're in the left-wing media and
you're doing the slicing because
uh here's well i'll just i'll just show
you this it's just this is a good taste
this is pretty much all mainstream media
this is this is how they're dealing with
it
here's nicole wallace on msnbc yesterday
talking to fauci and she's she's like
she could barely contain herself she's
gushing
falci um and no change there i suppose
either but let's
let's listen to this you spoke about my
emails
you look at my emails i never in the
email said anything derogatory
about president trump
well the true mark of someone is if they
look good even when their personal
emails come out so you passed the test
that very few of us
would pass dr anthony fauci thank you
for spending some time with us today
talking about all of it we're always
grateful to get some of your time
she's like she's giggling like a school
girl she can't contain herself
that's the true mark you you look so
good in the emails
it the the see the problem with the
emails
it's not so much the emails themselves
it's when you compare them
to what was being said
in public that's the issue all right um
naomi osaka is the world number two
tennis player
i admit i'd never heard of her until
this week
she's withdrawn from the french open
announced that she will step back from
tennis after a controversy erupted when
she skipped a post-match press
conference
osaka who won her opening match in the
tournament on sunday
uh also said she has suffered long bouts
of depression since winning the u.s open
in 2018. the 23 year old was fined 15
000
for refusing to attend the press
conference and was warned that she will
face further consequences if she did so
again
under the rules osaka must still meet
with the media for post-match press
conferences
upon requests um in a statement of
social media after her withdrawal she
said
i think now the best thing for the
tournament the other players and my
well-being is that i withdraw
so that everyone can get back to
focusing on tennis going into paris
um she uh let's see
she said osaka took to twitter shortly
after she skipped the press conference
to say that she sees the press
conferences which have have to be
attended by the winner and loser of a
match as kicking a person while they're
down
she said quote we're all we're often sat
there and asked questions
that we've been asked multiple times
before or asked questions that bring
doubt into our minds
and i'm not i'm just not going to
subject myself to people that doubt me
i've watched many clips of athletes
breaking down after a loss in the press
room
and i know uh you have as well i believe
that whole situation is kicking a person
while they're down
and i don't understand the reasoning
behind it so now she's she's uh
backing away and she's she's she
withdrew from the tournament
because it it doesn't it's um harmful to
her
mental health to have to sit and um
answer questions especially after you
lose
she doesn't want to be around people who
doubt her she wants to
you know hide from that now
the reason i didn't mention this story
at first because i really don't care
um i did like i said i didn't know who
this person was
and if that was all that happened just
she decides i don't want to be in the
tournament i don't want to answer
questions from the press
who cares great fine uh and and i'm not
one to sit here and defend the press
anyway
and and their rights to ask questions or
to you know
i i'm not interested in doing that
but the problem is that ever since she
made this announcement
she's now being celebrated for her
courage
and the final straw for me was yesterday
hillary clinton
sent out a tweet saying talking about uh
this athlete's what's her name again
naomi osaka
osaka talking about her courage and
saying we should celebrate her for her
courage
see now that's going overboard she wants
to withdraw from the tournament
who cares that's fine it's her own
choice
but let's not pretend that that's
courage
that's not courage any more than uh
lebron
james nba playoffs a couple nights ago
his team was losing badly
in in the fourth quarter and he storms
off the court before the game is over
and goes to the locker room
probably to protect his own mental
health because if
it felt bad he was kind of sad because
they were losing
never mind the fact that he's a grown
man allegedly
world famous athlete but he doesn't want
to sit there and be sad and everything
and it just makes him feel bad
so he went he went storming off the
court went to the locker room
it's it's like behavior that as a parent
you would not accept from your children
if they were playing sports if my son
was in basketball and they were losing
and he stormed off the court because he
was sad
we'd have real problems at home
so i would call this move from naomi
osaka courageous in the same way that
lebron james is courageous for storming
off the court
in the sense that it's it's not
courageous at all
you to shrink away from
a situation that makes you uncomfortable
to avoid
discomfort it may be understandable it's
a human instinct we all want to do that
but it's not courageous
so you want so if you want to tell me
let her make her own decisions
um respect her decisions fine cool
who cares but if you tell me that we
should
celebrate it as courage now there's a
problem
because that's not courage that's the
opposite of courage
shrinking away from difficult things
um avoiding discomfort that's the
opposite of courage
like by definition
another thing that i've had on the
docket for a couple days and i want to
play this for you
severe staffing shortages from fox news
severe staffing shortages at the san
francisco police department paired with
the local prosecutor's criminal first
agenda is creating
a dangerous situation on city streets
headed into the summer months according
to union president
tony montoya after one of his officers
left patrolling alone in chinatown was
violently a tackle to the ground by a
homeless man until bystanders intervened
now this is we have the security camera
footage it was released by the union
and uh you can see there's a homeless
man he was causing i don't know what he
was doing i think he was he was
harassing people
random people the cops are called one
cop shows up to the scenes a female
police officer
she tries to arrest him he tackles her
to the ground
and she's now powerless at this point
this is a this is a big guy he's a large
man
and uh who knows if he's on drugs or
whatever and he's on top of her
and uh it takes a whole bunch of
um bystanders intervening to pry him off
and maybe save her life
let's take a look at the at the video
here we have the security camera footage
i don't have no weapons
now he's fighting her
and she is completely outmatched
she's a you know a woman small of
stature
this guy's on top of her
one bystander intervenes that's not
enough another guy comes up
another guy runs out and they need four
guys
and eventually other police officers
show up all right
so i mean that that's uh you
talk about cur so there's some real
courage i think to to
be a bystander and so often in these
situations we've seen this a million
times
um usually something like that the the
footage we would
see that was the security camera footage
but usually we're not getting security
camera footage we're getting cell phone
footage because the bystanders rather
than intervening
and doing the right thing they just sit
around filming it so that they can be
the first one to get it on social media
and get all those sweet social media
likes
and hits but in this case bystanders
did the right thing got involved which
which they should be lauded for that
but there's so much going on here to be
analyzed
first of all when you
defund police departments
and you have fewer police this is the
kind of thing that happens
now if those bystanders had not run in
to help her what would have happened
she could have been killed or she would
have been
fully justified and that doesn't mean
that she wouldn't end up getting
prosecuted for it by the way but she
would have been fully justified
especially if she didn't have any help
she would have been fully justified in
pulling out her gun and just shooting
the guy
because now she's in a fight for her
life she's in mortal danger she's got
this large
intoxicated crazy guy on top of her
and she's in fear for her life so she
would have been fully justified in
pulling out her gun and shooting him
it didn't go that way largely because
other people intervene if they weren't
there
then that could have gone a fatal
direction
because she's just one police officer
there dealing with this
and that's the thing when you have fewer
police officers there's actually
no you don't end up with less violence
you end up with more violence in the
community because there are fewer people
there to enforce the law
but even the the interactions with the
public and police
become more dangerous for everyone
involved
because they don't have backup they
don't have help they're going to have to
more quickly resort to
um to lethal means to defend themselves
in situations like this
and then also you know we have to
mention we've got the issue of um
the fact this is a female police officer
by herself patrolling responding to a
call like this
and credit to her i mean that that takes
courage as well but
what's what's the plan here
this is not this woman there are very
few
suspects especially men that this woman
would be able to
contain and take down on her own
even if you're a man even if you're a
large strong man
it still is very difficult to take
someone down
and contain them when they really don't
want to be contained
and especially if they're on drugs but
for a woman it's there's almost no
chance
the police officers are not are not
ninjas this is not kill bill
they might be trained but there's almost
no chance that that
female police officer could have been
able to
take that guy down
so what's the plan exactly you send
female cops out by themselves
they can be easily overpowered by almost
any suspect
it's just disaster waiting to happen and
that could have been a disaster if not
for the
courage of the of the bystanders all
right let's move to
reading the youtube comments this is
from
buff guy one i don't know if i'm
believing the username though he says
matt needs to get rid of the beard it's
run its course
you know what you need to get rid of
your life it's run its course
that was a little strong maybe that's
maybe a little bit overboard but i have
to defend my beard you know when you
i have to have to speak up in defense
for what's right um
let's see another comment says the
camera b angle
that's exciting no it suddenly takes the
storytelling mode from first person
looking in the camera to talking off
camera like an
interview i've always hated it ditch the
second camera
uh i let you know you could always rely
on the internet for that and and uh and
and comments for that there's there are
always going to be people who find a
reason to criticize and i do appreciate
that i really do
i don't even mean that sarcastically as
someone who myself i'm always looking to
criticize everything i
i appreciate that uh that you have
stepped up to the plate here
another comment says you were a kid in
the early 90s
there's hope after all
i have no idea what that means
and haley miller says do you purposely
not only pronounce uh kamela incorrectly
but also
differently each time i have
no idea what you mean i would never no i
would never
purposely mispronounce camille's uh
name that is very disrespectful and i
would never do it
well when you think about all the things
you want to do this summer
as the weather gets warmer things are
opened up
you know getting your normal life back
hopefully
i don't know what your your plans are
for the summer but i'm thinking your
plan
is not to spend time wandering around
auto parts stores and if it's not
that's why you need rockauto.com
rockauto.com if you need
auto parts if you've got your car
trouble you need anything for your car
rockauto.com is going to be a much
better option than
walking into a store having to answer a
bunch of questions you may not know the
answer all the questions
and then what are you going to find most
of the time they don't have the part
well we don't have that part we got to
order it
why bother with all that you just pull
out your phone go to rockauto.com
always going to find the lowest prices
possible and
at the same time the although the
catalog is extensive and they've got
endless endless supplies of parts
it's also really easy to navigate and
find exactly what you're looking for
so the catalog is unique easy to
navigate and you could quickly see all
the parts available for your vehicle and
you can choose the brand specifications
and prices you prefer
so go now to rockauto.com right now and
see all the parts available for your car
truck and as always remember to write
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box
so they know that we sent you and if
there's one thing we learned
about our government over the past year
it's that uh they hate freedom i think
we probably
knew that even before this year began or
this past year began if there's one
thing we need to start actively doing
though
it's fighting to keep ours and that's
why you need to pick up ben shapiro's
new book the authoritarian moment and
prepare yourself for whatever else our
almighty rulers have waiting up their
sleeves so if you understand the threat
this poses to our future
it's time to read up on the truth in
order to stand up to the woke the
authoritarian moment is now available
for pre-order at amazon barnes noble
and any other major bookseller now let's
get to our daily cancellation
so yesterday the name paxton smith was
trending nationwide on social media and
is still trending last i checked
before i figured out who this person is
and why they've become notable i saw
that such luminaries as hillary clinton
once again and sarah silverman and
jessica valenti and a bunch of people
who with pronoun pronouns in their bio
were extolling her bravery and that was
enough for me to know that whatever
paxton smith did
it probably wasn't good and my instincts
were correct here's usa today with the
story it says a high school
valedictorian from texas flipped the
script on school officials by using her
graduation speech
to speak out against the state's newly
signed law banning abortions as early as
six weeks after conception
paxton smith has submitted and entirely
had submitted an entirely different
speech on the effect of the media
on young minds to school officials for
the commencement ceremony
at lake highlands high school in dallas
on sunday but smith
said it was important to use the moment
to criticize a controversial abortion
law signed by governor greg abbott last
month smith called the legislation a war
on the rights of your mothers a war on
the rights of your sisters a war on the
rights of your daughters
we cannot stay silent smith said to the
graduating class smith was able to
finish her speech without interruption
it's not unusual for school officials to
intervene
when a student deviates from an approved
graduation speech the impromptu speech
has
prompted the richardson independent
school district to re-evaluate its set
of protocols
regarding future student speeches well
of course
they weren't going to intervene during
this stunt as they would have if her
politics were different
they wouldn't want to be accused of
being agents of the patriarchy or
whatever
now as reluctant as i am to give this
stun any more attention
i do think it's worthwhile to listen to
a portion of the girl's
pro-abortion diatribe because we can
learn from it
we're not learning the things she wants
us to learn but still i do find it quite
instructive so let's listen now
i have dreams and hopes and ambitions
every girl graduating today does and we
have spent our entire lives working
towards our future
and without our input and without our
consent
our control over that future has been
stripped away from
us i am terrified
that if my contraceptives fail i am
terrified
that if i am raped then my hopes and
aspirations and dreams and efforts for
my future will no longer matter
i hope that you can feel how
gut-wrenching that is
i hope you can feel how dehumanizing it
is
to have the autonomy over your own body
taken away from you
and i cannot give up this platform
to promote complacency and peace
when there is a war on my body and a war
on my rights
a war on the rights of your mothers a
war
on the rights of your sisters a war on
the rights of your
daughters we cannot stay silent
well that was all a bunch of muddled
garbage
her reasoning is as morally bankrupt as
it is intellectually vacuous none of the
claims she made there were remotely true
but i don't blame her she's just a kid
17 18 years old high school student um
i blame instead the adults in her life
and the cultural and political forces in
our country that have convinced this
young lady that her dreams and hopes and
ambitions
are dependent on her ability to murder
her children
i mean that's what she believes and i
believe that she really believes that
and i i don't really blame her for
believing such hideous nonsense as
it's what she's been conditioned to
believe so let's think about this just
for a moment
um paxton says that her dreams hopes and
ambitions
hinge on her right to dismember any
future babies that she might conceive
she says indeed that her aspirations for
the future will quote no longer matter
if she's not able to kill a baby after a
heartbeat is detected
she needs to have unfettered unlimited
access to
any and all child killing resources or
else her life is over and all of her
plans for the future
are but dust and ash now in order to
hold this
demented point of view she must first of
all believe that human life in the womb
is
totally worthless she must see pregnancy
as a sort of zero-sum
game either she dehumanizes her child
or she is dehumanized if she's forced to
treat her child as a human
then she's no longer human there's only
so much humanity to go around
she thinks there's only there's only
room for one human between the two of
them
a law that would potentially prevent her
from throwing her own children away like
so much garbage
is a law that deprives her of humanity
that's the way she sees it
and she must also believe that there is
no reliable way to prevent the birth of
a future baby without abortion
she mentions rape but far less than one
percent of all abortions are due to rape
in 99 99 plus percent of cases
babies are conceived through an
intentional act
by mother and father and then they're
killed because either mother or father
or both
decide that they don't want to deal with
the natural results of that intentional
act
now i don't know i'm beginning to see a
way to prevent pregnancy
that works literally 100 of the time
and you don't have to kill anybody third
perhaps most disturbingly
in order to say everything that she just
said
paxton must like believe
that there is no way for a woman to
fulfill her ambitions and chase her
dreams
once she has a baby she equates
motherhood
with death itself once you become a
mother
your goals your purpose your very life
are over
and this is not a straw man of what she
said it is literally what she said
our control over our future has been
stripped away from us she said my dreams
for my future
no longer matter this is the language
she's using
and she's being applauded for it she
sees motherhood
as the end of all dreams the
disintegration of hope
the crushing of ambition it is a
dreary miserable fearful view of
of the world and life and womanhood and
it's exactly what the abortion industry
wants her to believe
exactly like what people like hillary
clinton want her to believe
and tell her to believe and it's
entirely false
little does paxton know but you don't
have to give up any
dreams or any goals when you become a
mother
you might end up changing your goals
because your priorities have changed
and become less centered around yourself
but there's no reason why any particular
ambition
must change or be abandoned it's true
that it can be more difficult more
challenging
to do certain things as a parent but
nothing has become
impossible that was possible before
in fact as a parent far from having your
dreams erased
you now have your dreams multiplied you
have
additional hopes and plans for the
future
i would even say greater hopes and plans
your designs for your life have expanded
not shrunk abortion does not preserve
your ability to fulfill your goals you
don't need abortion for that
i mean you're a strong woman right
you're a fighter a go-getter
isn't that what you you would say about
yourself
isn't that what the culture tells you to
believe about yourself
well it does say that and tell you that
but then it also tells you that you're
incapable of achieving your goals and
being a mother at the same time
so you have to choose one or the other
one thing must die
your child or your dreams
that's what the culture tells you that's
what feminists tell you
it tells you that that you're strong but
then treats you like you're weak
like you need to pay someone a man most
likely to kill your child
just so that you can be happy and
successful in life
this is a message of helplessness of
dependence
of fear and that's what the abortion
industry says to women like paxton
be afraid be very afraid your life is
over if you get pregnant
the only way out is through bloodshed
the only way out is through death
and destruction it's a lie
and the worst thing you know is to
realize what a lie it was
only after it's too late after you've
already made the fateful choice
and you've given up the one thing you
can never get back
your child you don't have to give up
your
career ambitions forever just because
you have a kid
that's something you can still have you
give up your child you can never have
your child back
many women whether they'll say it
publicly or not and many will say it
publicly if only people would listen
have exercised their right to choose
quote unquote
and then lived a little longer and
looked at their lives and realized that
all they have now that's worth having
they still could have had with a child
but the one thing that was the most
worth having
they gave up forever
they killed the greater dream for the
sake of the lesser one
it was a choice yeah but a false choice
and it can't be undone
that's the path that paxton is already
walking towards
because she's been brainwashed to
believe that her dreams depend on
death and that is a horrible thing
and so all the people who have convinced
paxton smith of that lie and so many
other young women of that same lie
are today canceled and to say that
they're canceled i think is is uh
doesn't quite go far enough
um but that's it we'll leave it there
for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show was produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. leaked
emails from dr fauci show that we were
right about the virus from
the beginning we were right hate to say
that you know how much i hate to say i
told you so the new york accounting
program won't let whites apply
and ron desantis faces a serious
challenge for governor
in 2022 check it out on the michael
knowles show